MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
NEW PHOTOGRAPHS THIS MORNING OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP WEARING A MASK
PUBLICLY FOR THE FIRST TIME
YESTERDAY, DURING HIS VISIT TO
WALTER REED HOSPITAL.
THE PRESIDENT WHO MET WITH
WOUNDED SOLDIERS AND MEDICAL
WORKERS TOLD REPORTERS HE LOVES
MASKS IN THE APPROPRIATE
LOCATIONS BUT STILL BELIEVES
THEY HAVE A TIME AND PLACE
JOINING US RIGHT NOW WITH
REACTION IS THE EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION, DONALD TRUMP JR.
AND DON IT IS GOOD TO SEE
YOU THIS MORNING THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
>> MY PLEASURE, MARIA HOW ARE
YOU?
MARIA: YEAH, GREAT INTERESTING
TO SEE YOUR DAD WITH A MASK,
OBVIOUSLY THINGS ARE SERIOUS,
YOU’VE GOT THE POTENTIAL OF THE
SECOND SPIKE.
HOW IS KIMBERLY DOING?
WE KNOW KIMBERLY HAS CONTRACTED
COVID ALONG WITH A TOP
CONVENTION PERSON.
IS SHE OKAY?
>> SHE’S 100% FINE.
SHE’S ZERO SYMPTOMS, ZERO
ANYTHING.
WE’RE IN QUARANTINE OBVIOUSLY,
AND I AM TOO BECAUSE OF
PROXIMITY BUT OTHER THAN THAT
YOU REALLY WOULDN’T KNOW THAT
THERE’S ANYTHING EVEN GOING ON,
SO, ITS BEEN GOOD.
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES, IT’S AS
GOOD AS IT CAN GET AND I ALSO
SAID MY FATHER LOOKED PRETTY
GOOD IN THE MASK THE OTHER DAY
AND WHAT PEOPLE ALSO HAVE TO
REALIZE WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT
THERE BEING A TIME AND PLACE,
ANYONE WHO COMES INTO PROXIMITY
WITH HIM IS LITERALLY TESTED
THAT DAY, IS LITERALLY TESTED
MOMENTS BEFORE THEY ALLOW ACCESS
, SO HE’S OBVIOUSLY GOING
TO BE MUCH LESS SUSCEPTIBILE TO
THIS THAN ANYONE ELSE, BECAUSE
LITERALLY THERE IS A DAILY
SCREENING PROCESS IF YOU’RE
GOING TO EVEN BE WITHIN
PROXIMITY TO HIM SO I THINK
THAT’S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
NOTE BUT WHEN HE’S GOING TO
WALTER REED TO VISIT OUR SICK
AND WOUNDED SOLDIERS HE’S GOING
TO TAKE THAT VERY SERIOUSLY.
MARIA: YEAH, BUT PEOPLE ARE
TAKING SERIOUSLY THE IDEA THAT
WE ARE SEEING A SECOND WAVE
POTENTIALLY AND SPIKES IN SOME
HOTSPOTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN FOR THE
CONVENTION DON AND WHAT
ABOUT THE IDEA THAT LOOK, THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE ALREADY SAID
THEY’RE GOING TO DO A VIRTUAL
CONVENTION.
THERE ARE POLLS THAT HAVE BIDEN
EITHER TIED WITH TRUMP OR
ACTUALLY LEADING DONALD TRUMP.
YOUR THOUGHTS OF ALL OF THESE
WORRIES GOING INTO THE
CONVENTION AND THEN OF
COURSE THE ELECTION.
>> WELL I THINK FOR THE
DEMOCRATS OF COURSE THEY
WANT TO DO A VIRTUAL CONVENTION
BECAUSE THERE’S NO ENTHUSIASM
FOR JOE BIDEN.
HE CAN’T GET PEOPLE TO SHOW UP
IF HE WAS ABLE TO DO RALLIES SO
THIS WHOLE SCENARIO IS REALLY,
THE ULTIMATE BEST CASE SCENARIO
FOR JOE BIDEN AND HIS CAMPAIGN.
THEY DON’T WANT HIM SPEAKING TO
REPORTERS, THEY DON’T WANT HIM
AD-LIB.
HONESTLY THEY DON’T EVEN WANT
HIM ON THE TELEPROMPTER BECAUSE
HE CAN’T EVEN GET THAT RIGHT SO
FOR THEM IT’S SORT OF THE
ULTIMATE.
WITH OUR CONVENTION THERE’S A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT WANT TO DO IT
AND BE ENTHUSIASTIC BUT WE CAN
DO THAT AND DO IT SAFELY.
WE CAN TAKE THE NECESSARY
PRECAUTIONS AND PROTECT THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO BE
THERE.
WE CAN IMPLEMENT THINGS THAT YOU
WOULDN’T NECESSARILY NORMALLY
IMPLEMENT AT A CONVENTION TO DO
SO, SO THEY’RE GOING TO TAKE IT
VERY SERIOUSLY AND WE’LL DO A
GREAT JOB AND IT’S GOING TO BE
AN AWESOME EVENT.
MARIA: WELL WHAT DOES THE
PRESIDENT NEED TO GET THESE
NUMBERS UP?
ARE YOU BUYING THESE POLLS?
YOU LOOK LIKE ONE AFTER THE NEXT
, IS A REAL TIGHT RACE
IN MANY CASES, BIDEN IS LEADING
THE PRESIDENT.
>> WELL LISTEN I THINK WHEN YOU
HAVE THE MEDIA WHERE MEDIA HAS
JUST TOTALLY ADVOCATED THEIR
POSITION TO OBJECTIVELY LOOK AT
BOTH SIDES, THEY’RE NOT LOOKING
INTO ANY OF BIDEN’S PAST THEY’RE
NOT LOOKING INTO ANY HISTORY,
THEY’RE NOT LOOKING INTO HIS
FAMILY, NOT LOOKING AT HOW
INSANELY SOFT HE’S BEEN ON CHINA
THROUGHOUT HIS ENTIRE CAREER AND
LET’S NOT FORGET THIS IS A 50
YEAR CAREER IN WASHINGTON D.C.
THEY’RE TRYING TO RUN HIM LIKE
HE’S A MODERATE OUTSIDER.
THIS GUY IS FROM THE SWAMP, SO
THEY WANT TO DO WHATEVER THEY
CAN TO KEEP THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FROM ACTUALLY SEEING BIDEN.
HE HASN’T BEEN DEFIED IN THE
MEDIA IS TRYING TO MAKE SURE
NO ONE GETS TO DEFINE JOE BIDEN,
BECAUSE ONCE HE IS, YOU’LL SEE
HOW TERRIBLE THIS NOTION
COULD BE FOR AMERICA.
MARIA: WHICH IS WHY YOU’RE OUT
WITH A UPCOMING BOOK, LIBERAL
PRIVILEGE.
YOU’RE GOING TO TALK A LOT ABOUT
BIDEN IN THIS BOOK RIGHT?
YOU’RE SELF-PUBLISHING A BOOK?
>> 100% I GUESS ONE OF THE ONLY
POSITIVE THINGS OF QUARANTINE
FOR THE LAST FEW MONTHS WAS I
HAD A LOT OF FREE TIME AND I WAS
LOOKING INTO IT AND ACTUALLY
WENT ON AND HIRED A RESEARCHER
JUST TO DOUBT MYSELF BECAUSE I
SAID IF THE MEDIA IS GOING TO
TOTALLY NEGLECT THIS GUY, THIS
HISTORY ESPECIALLY NOW IN
THE POST-COVID-19 WORLD WHERE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE TO DEAL WITH CHINA
AND DEAL TOUGH WITH CHINA WHICH
IS WHAT DONALD TRUMP THAT’S HIS
WHEEL HOUSE, HE’S THE ONLY GUY
TO DO IT IN THE MODERN AMERICAN
HISTORY, YOU KNOW THAT JOE BIDEN
CAN SELL THIS NOTION OF WELL NOW
WE’RE GOING TO BE BUY AMERICAN
AFTER 50 YEARS OF LEGISLATION
THAT SENT OUR JOBS, THAT SENT
OUR AMERICAN DREAM, TO CHINA?
I’M SITTING THERE LOOKING
WHETHER IT’S HUNTER BIDEN,
WHETHER IT’S JOE’S BROTHER,
WHETHER IT’S THE SISTER THE
ENTIRE FAMILY HAS ENRICHED
THEMSELVES OFF OF JOE BIDEN’S
PUBLICLY FUNDED OFFICE.
HE WON’T RELEASE HIS DOCUMENTS
FROM 30 SOMETHING YEARS IN THE
SENATE THAT ARE SITTING AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF DELAWARE.
THESE AREN’T LIKE PRIVATE NOTES
HE HAD AS A CITIZEN.
THIS WHILE HE WAS A SENATOR IN
THE UNITED STATES, PAID FOR BY
THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER, AND
SOMEHOW THAT’S MAGICALLY OFF
LIMITS?
YOU KNOW, BRETT KAVANAUGH’S HIGH
SCHOOL YEARBOOK WAS NOT OFF
LIMITS ACCORDING TO DEMOCRATS.
HIS HIGH SCHOOL YEARBOOK BUT JOE
BIDEN’S SENATE PAPERS NO, NO, WE
CAN’T TOUCH THIS SO IT’S ABOUT
HIPOCRACY AND ABOUT THE DOUBLE
STANDARD AND I CALLED IT LIBERAL
PRIVILEGE BECAUSE WE HEAR A LOT
ABOUT PRIVILEGE BUT LIBERAL
PRIVILEGE IS THE ULTIMATE
BECAUSE THEY CAN SAY ONE THING,
DO THE OTHER AND NEVER GET
CALLED ON IT.
MARIA: WELL LOOK IN THE MEANTIME
THE CRITICS OF YOUR FATHER
CONTINUE STEPPING IT UP, JUST IN
THE LAST TWO WEEKS YOU HAD THE
MAYOR OF NEW YORK ACTUALLY
PAINTING BLACK LIVES MATTER
MURAL RIGHT OUTSIDE OF TRUMP
TOWER ON FIFTH AVENUE IN NEW
YORK CITY.
THIS IS WHERE YOU WORK EVERY DAY
, RIGHT?
DO YOU PASS THIS NEW MURAL HERE?
HERE IS A SHOT OF THE MAYOR
ACTUALLY PAINTING IT RIGHT
OUTSIDE OF TRUMP TOWER.
YOUR REACTION.
>> WELL LISTEN ITED BE NICE IF
THE MAYOR ACTUALLY DID SOMETHING
TO HELP THE PEOPLE OF HIS CITY.
HE’S BUSY THEY’RE PLAYING ARTS
AND CRAFTS BUT WHAT HAS HE
ACTUALLY DONE OTHER THAN OVERSEE
THE DESTRUCTION OF NEW
YORK CITY?
THE GUYS, YOU KNOW, IT’S
LITERALLY GROSS IN COMPETENCE
BUT HE’LL GO THERE FOR A PHOTO O
P.
WHAT HAPPENED TO ALMOST
$1 BILLION THAT WERE LITERALLY
JUST LOST ON HIM AND HIS WIFE’S
PET PROJECTS IN NEW YORK CITY?
NOW HE WANTS TO DEFUND THE
POLICE AND TAKE $1 BILLION
OUT OF NEW YORK CITIES POLICE
DEPARTMENTS, BUDGET.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THAT?
YOU SEE POLICE OFFICERS RETIRING
IN DROVES.
YOU WANT TO STOP SENSELESS
KILLINGS?
LIKE GEORGE FLOYD GUESS WHAT THE
ANSWER IS NOT DRIVING
EXPERIENCED, DEDICATED, LOYAL,
POLICE OFFICERS INTO EARLY
RETIREMENT AND FILLING THAT VOID
WITH INEXPERIENCED PEOPLE WHO
MAY NOT HAVE QUALIFIED OTHERWISE
, BUT ARE ONLY GETTING
THE JOB BECAUSE YOU NEED SOMEONE
THERE.
THE GUY DOESN’T KNOW WHAT HE’S
DOING.
IT’S GROSS NEGLIGENCE, AND
HONESTLY, IT’S WORSE.
IT’S JUST SHEAR IN COMPETENCE,
BUT AGAIN, YOU CAN PLAY ARTS AND
CRAFTS FOR THE PHOTO OP AND IT’S
AS THOUGH ALL OF THE THINGS AND
ALL OF HIS FAILURES ARE TOTALLY
FORGOTTEN BUT THE MEDIA WILL
GIVE HIM THAT BENEFIT.
MARIA: YEAH, BUT IT’S GOING TO
KEEP GOING AND IN FACT, DEBLASIO
, HILLARY CLINTON
ALL WANT MAIL-IN VOTING I WANT
TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE THERE WAS A CITY COUNCIL
MAN, AMONG FOUR PEOPLE
FACING VOTER FRAUD CHARGES IN
NEW JERSEY WE’VE GOT STORIES OF
THIS DILUTION, MAIL-IN BALLOTS
FORCING ELECTION OFFICIALS IN
NEW YORK, PENNSYLVANIA, KENTUCKY
, TO TAKE TWO TIMES AS
LONG TO COUNT VOTES IN
PRIMARY ELECTIONS.
HOW MUCH OF THIS ELECTION IS
GOING TO BE MAIL-IN VOTING DO
YOU THINK, DON?
>> WELL THE DEMOCRATS WOULD
LIKE IT ALL TO BE MAIL-IN VOTING
YOU’VE SEEN THAT.
HOW OFTEN HAVE REPUBLICANS WON
AFTER THE FACT WHEN PEOPLE SAY
OH, LOOK MAGICALLY I FOUND A
BUCKET OF BALLOTS IN MY CAR ALL
DEMOCRATS FOUR DAYS LATER.
IT’S TRULY DISGUSTING OVER THE
WEEKEND WE SAW A CAT, A CAT
THAT HAS BEEN DEAD FOR 12 YEARS,
SINCE THE END OF THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION, GOT A VOTER
REGULATION FORMAT ITS HOME IN
ATLANTA.
THIS IS WHAT’S GOING ON.
A MAIL CLERK SOMEONE WHO WORKED
FOR THE U.S. POSTAL SERVICE
PLEADED GUILTY OVER THE WEEKEND
FOR  ALTERING BALLOTS.
YOU THINK THE DEMOCRATS AREN’T
TAKING FULL ADVANTAGE OF THIS?
THEY ARE RUNNING AROUND BRAGGING
THEY WERE ABLE TO MANIPULATE
TRUMP RALLIES ON TIK TOK BUT
THEY AREN’T TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
MAIL-IN VOTING.
DEMOCRATS EVEN SAID IT’S
TERRIBLE.
MARIA: THIS IS REALLY SERIOUS
STUFF GOING INTO THE ELECTION.
YOU’RE RIGHT.
REAL QUICK, FINAL QUESTION HERE,
DON.
WILL YOU RUN FOR THE MAYOR OF
NEW YORK?
>> NO.
MY ONLY FOCUS RIGHT NOW IS
MAKING SURE THAT MY FATHER WINS
IN 2020.
I SEE THE POLICIES THAT HE’S
DONE.
I SEE THE ECONOMIC RESULTS.
WE’VE SEEN IT IN THE JOB NUMBERS
DONALD TRUMP DID THE IMPOSSIBLE.
DONALD TRUMP ACCOMPLISHED THE
HOLY GRAIL OF AMERICAN
POLITICS, RAISING THE JOB NUMBER
S FOR PEOPLE, RAISING THE
MINIMUM WAGES FOR THE LOWEST
INCOME EARNERS, WATCHING THEIR
WAGES GO UP FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN MODERN HISTORY.
DONALD TRUMP DID IT ALL BEFORE.
HE’S THE GUY THAT CAN DO IT
AGAIN.
CLEARLY NOT SWAMP CREATURE JOE
BIDEN WHO HAS AN  ACCOMPLISHMENT
RECORD NON-EXISTENT IN 50 YEARS
IN WASHINGTON D.C.
MARIA: SO MAYBE YOU CONSIDER IT
AFTER THE PRESIDENT WINS THEN?
MAYOR OF NEW YORK.
>> I DON’T KNOW THAT’S NOT
REALLY MY KIND OF JOB BUT WHO